الينا من لندن السيده اليسا كنز رئيسه
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان
البريطاني
السيده اليسا هل يمكن وصف ما يجري الان
سواء مقاله بلانكن او ما تحدثت عنه
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه بانه بدا حراك دولي
لوقف الاقتتال في السودان
هناك عمل كبير يجري حاليا لمحاوله منع
اعمال العنف من التصعيد
وتحاول ان تحدث مع كثير من اطراف في
العالم للتاكد باننا نوقف هذا القطاع لانه
فقط وقف اطلاق النار وهو مفيد وجيد للشعب
السوداني وايضا لاخلاء الاجنبيه غادرت
سودان ما فرص نجاح اي حراك دبلوماسي الان
في ظل اولا تصلب المواقف على الارض وثانيا
انصباب او او يعني الجهود الان منصبه بشكل
كبير على اجلاء الدبلوماسيين والرعايه
الاجانب من داخل السودان ما فرص نجاح اي
محاوله لوقفه اطلاق النار
لابد ان نعمل الامل في الدبلوماسيه ولهذا
السبب لكل من يعمل في سلك الدوبلاسي يامل
ويامل تحقيق نتائج جيده ولكن نعم اتفق معك
ان فرص وقف اطلاق النار ضعيفه جدا لانه
الذي اتفقوا عليهم وقفه انهار بدون سبب
ولكن كل الحكومات تعمل بشكل كبير للتواصل
وفي اطلاق نار وايضا لاخلاء رعاياهم وهذه
الطريقه الوحيده لانهاء معاناه الشعب
السوداني وبالتالي وقف اطلاق النار امرنا
اساسي وحيويه تماما هل ممكن ان نعرف منكم
ما هي رؤيه بريطانيا لاولا وقفه لا النار
وربما بدا مفاوضات بين جينر لاين تفضي الى
تسليم السلطه الى مدنيين
الحكومه البريطانيه تريد
تحقيق انتقال سلمي للسلطه حيث يكون الشعب
السوداني امنين في بلادهم
وايقاف اعمال النهب والقتال التي شاهد على
حاليا الشعب السودان هو الذي يجب ان يقرر
مستقبله ولكنه امر محزن جدا ان فصيلين
عسكريين قرر حسم الامور لصالحهما للسيطره
على السلطه بدل التفكير بالشعب وما يحتاجه
الشعب السوداني طبعا بريطانيا ضمن ما تعرف
بالرباعيه والتي كثفت اتصالاتها فيما
يتعلق بالسودان بعد اندلاع الاشتباكات الى
اين وصلت هذه الاتصالات
انا ساحاول ان اصل
رئيسه اللجنه الخارجيه غدا لجنه يستعقد
جلسه حول مستقبل السودان
نقوم
جهود اخرى في المستقبل
وناقشه المستقبل ايضا انا لست عضو في
الحكومه وبالتالي ستكون بالتدقيق كل
الجهود لتبذلها الحكومه البريطانيه وكذلك
المجتمع الدولي طبعا البارحه رئيس الوزراء
السيد ريشيسونك اشار الى عمليه اجلاء
سريعه ومعقده من السودان لدبلوماسيين
وعائلاتهم هذا التوجه من الحكومه
البريطانيه ومن دول ايضا اخرى لاجلاء
الرعايه هل يشي بالضروره الى ان الامور
بحسب التقييم الغربي والتقييم البريطاني
طبعا بان الامور تتجه الى مزيد من التصعيد
في السودان بالايام المقبله
السبب اجلاء الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين
وكذلك دول اخرى هو
الخطر
عليهم وهذا الخطر وكبيرا والى لما شاهدنا
ان كثير من الدول تنقل
وتجلي موظفيها كما قلت انا لست في الحكومه
الاطلاع على المعلومات استخباريه لكن واضح
ان كان خطر حقيقي ووشيك عليهم والا لما
اخلوهم السيده اليسا كنز رئيسه لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان البريطاني
شكرا لك